bonsoir bernard de bain bonsoir ump de
saint-cyr l'école on va parler politique
avec vous municipal ce sera dans un
second temps tout d'abord on va parler
de ce grand chantier urbanisme la zac
renard sur l'ancienne emprise de la
caserne renard 25 hectares 1500
logements
trois réunions de concertation qui se
sont déroulées au cours des dernières
semaines
quel bilan vous faites de ces réunions
de concertation je crois franc succès la
fréquentation était importante les
enseignants se sont intéressé 1 à
l'avenir de ce quartier une 40 à 50
personnes à chaque séance certains sont
venus à plusieurs séances des gens
vraiment très motivé quelles sont les
questions justement qui se pose qui
interpelle sur l'arrivée de ce futur
quartier on parle d'une ville dans la
ville c'est quelque chose d'important
c'est pas juste quelques habitations qui
vont qui vont sortir de terre
c'est une continuité c'est la
possibilité de rejoindre la partie est
et la partie ouest saint cyr au nord de
l'école militaire
alors qu alors l'heure actuelle n'y a
rien et c'est aussi la possibilité de
dessiner un nouveau quartier mais c'est
un nouveau quartier c'est pas une
nouvelle ville on espère bien que les
saints série impose non seulement se
l'approprier mais profiter de ces larges
zahlé de ces espaces verts nombreux pour
venir s'y promener mais il est là
l'enjeu parce que vous nous dites ce
n'est pas une ville dont la ville mais
1500 logements pourrait croire que enfin
la population va augmenter de combien
d'habitants
vous projetez qu'elle offre les fixes
les statistiques considère que sur 1400
logements il ya à peu près 400 logements
qui sont du mouvement interne à la ville
et puis au fait de la décohabitation
donc à peu près 1000 logements
donc effectivement des problèmes de
circulation d'amélioration des
transports en commun et ça fait partie
de nous
deux années de travail qui est quelle
sera la suite justement de ces
différentes réunions de concertation et
des inquiétudes peut-être qu'ils sont
sortis sur la circulation va s'y
attarder d'ailleurs mais peut-être les
inquiétudes sont sortis et et ensuite
vous allez modifier des plans qu'est ce
qui va changer un certain nombre de
questions qui effectivement appel à
faire des modifications certaines
notamment en matière de circulation
il y a eu beaucoup d'interrogations
concernant les espaces verts
l'environnement les équipements publics
dont certains craignent qu'il soit déjà
plein à cause des habitants du nouveau
quartier
c'est pour ça que de toute façon ainsi
en matière de sport on a déjà en vue une
nouvelle salle des sports
mais sur la circulation quelles sont les
modifications vous allez apporter
qu'est-ce que vous avez imaginé qu est
ce qu il va falloir modifier par exemple
deux choses importantes ça suffira pas
mais deux choses importantes
la première c'est une liaison est-ouest
par le nord qui permettra de contourner
la ville en venant de soi de la route de
bailly soit de fontenay le fleury
la deuxième chose qui est en cours de
travail avec le conseil général sous le
doux dirrell l'idée première de monsieur
françois de mazières le maire de
versailles
c'est un contournement ouest est par une
déviation de la rd 7 le long des rails
du tram train et les travaux se feront
en même temps la circulation est
difficile dans sa serre l'école ce n'est
pas ce nouveau quartier qui va peut-être
changer les choses on l'espère en tout
cas ça pourrait éventuellement modifiée
mais il ya beaucoup de trafic les
difficultés avec les transports en
commun également aujourd'hui vous pouvez
rassurer les habitants de san siro même
ceux qui n'habitent pas essentielle mais
qui passe par saint cyr ce ne sera pas
pire avec ce nouveau quartier on va on
va je crois avoir beaucoup
d'améliorations et ne serait-ce que
le matin vous avez une queue très
importante sur la rd7 donc cette route
qui vient de qu'il vient de la vallée de
la seine jusqu'à 5,6 pour les gens qui
fréquentent justement
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
particulièrement ou bien ceux qui
veulent accéder à la 86 et bien cette la
déviation et le tram-train vont
permettre de soulager une partie du
trafic
on a évoqué la question de la
circulation l'imaginent aussi ce sont
les aménagements des questions peut être
porté là dessus lors des différentes
réunions de concertation est dans le
cadre de l'ouverture de cette zac renard
quels sont les équipements que vous
souhaiteriez voir arriver sur ce nouveau
quartier voici quelques réponses
on semble commercial
puisque tout souscrire au tour des
autres villes qu'on n'a pas nous quoi
plus de commerces et plus de vide en
centre-ville ou un centre un vrai centre
existant des écoles pour les futurs
parents crèche je sais qu'il ya un
gymnase qui est prévu et puis à tous des
espaces verts des terrains de sport
gymnase tout savoir principalement qu'il
y ait beaucoup plus de l'entreprise
c'est ce qui manque à saint cyr
j'attends surtout des logements et est
un peu je crois qu'on m'a dit aussi
qu'ils allaient construire un centre
commercial la rage du côté de des
racines cher donc ce ne serait pas moi
ça serait pas mal une partie de
logements en accession à la propriété
pour les locataires actuels à un local
approprié par rapport à notre
association par rapport à vue qu'on
accueille quand même un certain nombre
de l'adhérent on a plus de mille
adhérents donc on aimerait que ça soit
dans un cadre bien approprié et vous
allez répondre pendant ce micro trottoir
à la question que j'allais vous posez
tout est prévu une maison des
associations pour répondre à ce que
disait ce monsieur de 1000 mètres carrés
c'est quand même déjà quelque chose de
considérable
une partie commerciale qui ne sera pas
prévu sur la zac renard puisque la zac
renard dans sa partie nord ça sera des
entreprises mais la partie commerciale
c'est sur les 8 hectares qui jouxte la
zac et qui sont à aéroports de paris
donc ça erpent de pareilles on les en
gros but la semaine dernière
ça avance de leur côté et là ça sera une
partie purement commercial epic
équipements sportifs également entendu
parler m d'équipements sportifs écoles
naturellement puisqu'on l'a 16 classes
qui vont ouvrir de crèche en tout
soixante dix berceaux supplémentaires
c'est le dernier quartier de la commune
une organisation strathairn en l'air
j'ai fini la commune d'abus de terrain
le seul terrain qui nous restent qui
fait aussi huit hectares
il est en pleine de versailles il est
inconstructible en zone naturelle il va
être aménagée justement profitant de
l'aménagement de cette grenade et ses
eaux
au sein de ce terrain que passera
justement la déviation nord les premiers
logements sont attendus pour 2015 c'est
bien ça et puis le quartier ensuite la
réalisation va s'étendre sur une dizaine
d'années